TO COVER BEYOND THIS TOO.
THANK YOU ALL.
MORE THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
WE'LL TURN NOW TO THE RADICAL
EXTREME SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC
PARTY TONIGHT.
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, SHOULD
BE ALARMED.
JUST 24 HOURS AGO, ALL OF THE
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR THE
HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE LAND,
BASICALLY PUSHED THE VENEZUELA
STYLE SOCIALISM AS A SOLUTION TO
ALL OF AMERICA'S PROBLEMS.
BY THE WAY, THEY DIDN'T TALK
ONCE ABOUT THE AMERICAN ECONOMY
AND THE REVIVAL UNDER DONALD
TRUMP.
SHOCKING?
NOT EVEN A SINGLE QUESTION FROM
THEIR FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA MOB.
THEY CALLED FOR A HOSTILE
GOVERNMENT TAKEOVER OF THE
ENTIRE PRIVATE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY WITH THE PROPOSALS TO
KICK ALL OF THE AMERICANS OFF OF
THE PRIVATE HEALTH CARE PLANS.
NOT AN OPTION.
THEY CALLED FOR A HOSTILE
GOVERNMENT TAKEOVER OF THE
PRIVATE ENERGY SECTOR PUTTING
ALL OIL AND GAS COMPANIES OUT OF
BUSINESS.
HATE TO TELL YOU, THAT'S THE
LIFE BLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY.
AND, BOY, WHAT A STEP BACK THAT
WOULD BE NOW THAT WE ARE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS ENERGY
INDEPENDENT UNDER TRUMP.
THEY CALL FOR GOVERNMENT-RUN
UNIVERSAL CHILD CARE, PREK,
GOVERNMENT-MANDATED WAGES.
OH, LET'S SEE, VACATION, HEALTHY
FOOD, RETIREMENT, EVERYTHING IS
FREE, FREE, FREE.
THEY EVEN PUSHED GOVERNMENT
MANDATED GUN CONFISCATION.
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
SOCIALISM 101.
IT IS NOW THE STATUS QUO.
THERE ARE NO MODERATES INSIDE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOW, WE START OUR ANALYSIS WITH
CREEPY SLEEPY CRAZY JOE 3P0.
HIS POLL NUMBERS HAVE TAKEN A
DIVE AND FOR GOOD REASON.
IF YOU EVER HAD A FASTBALL, IT'S
LONG GONE.
I DON'T THINK HE EVEN HAS A
SOFTBALL.
AND BY MOST ACCOUNTS, BIDEN'S
DEBATE PERFORMANCE WAS A
RAMBLING, CONFUSED DISASTER.
THE ONLY PERSON INTERRUPTING JOE
WAS JOE.
LOOKING AT THE SCREEN.
ALL STARTS WITH AN APPARENT
PROBLEM INSIDE OF BIDEN'S MOUTH.
VERY BIZARRE, THIS WHOLE THING
HERE.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> A MEASURED TO REQUIRE
EXTENDED BACKGROUND CHECKS DIED
ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
IF YOU COULDN'T GET IT DONE
AFTER SANDY HOOK, WHY SHOULD
VOTERS GIVE YOU ANOTHER CHANCE.
>> I'M THE ONLY ONE UP HERE THAT
EVER BEAT THE NRA NATIONALLY.
>> Sean: BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IT
ONLY GOT WORSE FROM THERE.
NOT A GOOD NIGHT FOR BIDEN.
HERE'S MORE TAPE.
>> THE OPTION I'M PROPOSING IS A
MEDICARE FOR ALL -- MEDICARE FOR
CHOICE.
THE PRESIDENT -- MY FRIEND FROM
VERMONT.
>> A YOUNG COUNCILMAN -- PLAY
THE RADIO, MAKE SURE THE
TELEVISION -- MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
THE RECORD PLAYER ON AT NIGHT,
THE PHONE -- MAKE SURE THE KIDS
HEAR WORDS.
I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: HATE TO SAY IT, I DON'T
WANT TO SEE HIS MEDICAL RECORDS,
HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S AGED 20 YEARS
SINCE HE REFT OFFICE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
BIDEN'S PERFORMANCE WAS SO BAD
SOME OF THE OTHER DEMOCRATS ON
STAGE ACTUALLY QUESTIONED HIS
STATE OF MIND.
UH-OH, THEY WENT THERE.
TAKE A LOOK.
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO BUY IT --
>> YOU JUST SAID THAT, YOU JUST
SAID TWO MINUTES AGO THEY WOULD
HAVE TO BUY IN.
YOU SAID THEY WOULD HAVE TO BUY
IN.
ARE YOU FORGETTING WHAT YOU SAID
TWO MINUTES AGO?
>> IT WILL AUTOMATICALLY BE
ENFORCED.
>> ARE YOU FORGETTING WHAT YOU
SAID TWO MINUTES AGO?
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT YOU SAID
TWO MINUTES AGO THAT THEY HAD TO
BUY IN.
AND NOW YOU'RE SAYING THEY DON'T
HAVE TO -- YOU'RE FORGETTING
THAT.
>> THERE ARE MOMENTS THAT YOU
LISTEN TO JOE BIDEN AND YOU JUST
WONDER.
BUT I DON'T KNOW -- LOOK --
>> SENATOR, ARE YOU SAYING HE'S
TOO OLD TO BE PRESIDENT.
>> I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
I LISTENED TO JOE BIDEN OVER THE
YEARS AND FELT LIKE THERE WERE
TIMES THAT HE IS GOING ON OR
MEANDERING HIS -- IN HIS --
>> UH-OH.
THEY'RE GOING THERE.
MAYBE JUST HAD A LAELLY BAD
NIGHT.
MAYBE HE'S NOT A GREAT DEBATER.
MAYBE HE'S NOT GOOD AT SPEAKING
AND CAMPAIGNING.
SARAH PALIN I THOUGHT BEAT HIM
IN THAT DEBATE HANDILY.
IF BIDEN LIMPS ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE AND WINS THE NOMINATION, I
THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE
HAPPY WITH THAT RESULT.
NO MATTER WHO THE PRESIDENT
FACES IN THE GENERAL ELECTION,
WE CAN ALL EXPECT DEMOCRATS TO
ONCE AGAIN WEAPONIZE THE
POLITICS OF RACE.
WE SEE IT EVERY TWO AND FOUR
YEARS.
I'VE GIVEN THE HISTORY ON THIS
SHOW MANY, MANY TIMES.
THEY PRETTY MUCH CALLED HALF OF
AMERICA RACIST, WHITE SUPREMIST.
IT'S RACIST, MISOGYNIST,
XENOPHOBIC, HOMOPHOBIC.
THEY WANT GRANDMA AND GRANDPA TO
EAT DOG FOOD AND CAT FOOD BEFORE
THEY HAVE PAUL RYAN THROW THEM
OVER A CLIFF.
DIDN'T CHANGE LAST NIGHT.
THEY WERE IN RARE FORM.
>> RACISM IN AMERICA IS ENDEMIC,
IT'S FOUNDATIONAL.
WE CAN MARK THE CREATION OF THIS
COUNTRY NOT AT THE FOURTH OF
JULY, 1776 BUT AUGUST 20, 1619
WHEN THE FIRST KIDNAPPED
AFRICANS WERE BROUGHT TO THIS
COUNTRY AGAINST HIS WILL IN
BONDAGE.
>> RACISM.
>> RACIAL BIAS.
>> SYSTEMIC RACISM.
>> RACISM.
>> RACIST WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> RACISM.
>> RACIST.
>> SYSTEMIC RACISM.
>> INSTITUTIONAL SEGREGATION IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> NOW LAST NIGHT WHEN DEMOCRATS
WEREN'T BUSY PLAYING THE RACE
CARD, THEY DEDICATED A LOT OF
TIME TO REALLY PUSHING THEIR
INSANE SOCIALIST POLICIES,
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
VERY EXPENSIVE.
YOU CAN'T HAVE PRIVATE
INSURANCE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ON MEDICARE FOR ALL, COSTS
ARE GOING TO GO UP FOR WEALTHIER
INDIVIDUALS AND COSTS ARE GOING
TO GO UP FOR GIANT CORPORATIONS.
BUT FOR HARDWORKING FAMILIES
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY, COSTS ARE
GOING TO GO DOWN AND THAT'S HOW
IT SHOULD WORK.
>> EVERY THANK YOUDY DONE SHOWS
THAT MEDICARE FOR ALL IS THE
MOST COST-EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO
PROVIDING HEALTH CARE TO EVERY
MAN, WOMAN, AND CHILD IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> ANYONE WHO CAN'T AFFORD IT
GETS AUTOMATICALLY ENROLLED IN
THE MEDICARE-TYPE OPTION WE
HAVE.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
OF THE 160 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
LIKE THEIR HEALTH CARE NOW, THEY
CAN KEEP IT.
>> Sean: NOW, WHEN YOU HEAR
MEDICARE FOR ALL WITH NO PRIVATE
INSURANCE OPTION, OKAY, BAD AS
OBAMA CARE KEEP YOUR DOCTOR PLAN
SAVE MONEY WAS, THINK ABOUT THAT
1,000 TIMES WORSE WITH NO EXIT
ESCAPE HATCH AS IT STANDS NOW
BECAUSE OBAMA CARE, NEARLY 40%
OF ALL U.S. COUNTY, NEARLY HALF
OF THE COUNTRY, THEY ONLY HAVE
ONE INSURANCE OPTION.
AND THE OBAMA CARE MARKET.
ONLY ONE CHOICE THAT'S 40% OF
THE COUNTRY.
PREMIUMS, YEAH, NOBODY IS SAVING
MONEY.
PREMIUMS HAVE SKYROCKETED.
AND MANY PEOPLE LOST THEIR
DOCTORS AND THE FEDERAL PRICE
TAG FOR ALL OF THIS SUFFERING
WILL BE TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
UNDER MEDICARE FOR ALL, THAT
SYSTEM WILL EVEN BE WORSE.
YOU DON'T GET TO KEEP YOUR
DOCTOR PLAN, IN FACT, IN A
MEDICARE FOR ALL SYSTEM, EVERY
AMERICAN WILL EVEN LOSE THEIR
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE.
THE GOVERNMENT WOULD BE THE ONLY
INSURER.
AND GUESS WHAT?
TO TOP IT OFF, YOUR TAXES,
THEY'RE GOING TO EXPLODE.
THAT'S RIGHT.
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE STUDIES.
LOOK AT BERNIE'S MEDICAID --
MEDICARE FOR ALL PLAN, COMES
WITH AN ESTIMATED PRICE TAG OF
24 TO 36 TRILLION -- THAT'S WITH
A T, DOLLARS OVER TEN YEARS.
IN OTHER WORDS, OUR ENTIRE
FEDERAL BUDGET IS ONLY $4
TRILLION A YEAR.
TO PUT IT ANOTHER WAY, ALL OF
YOUR INCOME TAXES WILL NEED TO
PRETTY MUCH DOUBLE JUST TO COVER
THAT COST ON THAT ONE PROGRAM.
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE GREEN
NEW DEAL.
AND THERE'S MORE.
IT'S ALMOST EVERY DEMOCRAT,
YEAH, THEY SUPPORT A VERSION OF
THE INSANELY EXPENSIVE GREEN NEW
DEAL, THE BATTLE SO-CALLED
CLIMATE CHANGE.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
BERNIE SANDERS, HE WANTS TO
SPEND A WHOPPING -- TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT, SCRATCHING MY
CONSERVATIVE HEAD HERE, $16
TRILLION.
$16 TRILLION.
EVEN SO-CALLED MODERATE AMY
CLOBECHAR HAS A PLAN THAT COSTS
MORE THAN $1 TRILLION.
THAT'S ON THE LOW END.
THAT'S THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG
FOR DEMOCRATS AND THEIR BIG
SOCIALIST PLANS, LITERALLY, TO
TAKE THE GREATEST SYSTEM OF
WEALTH CREATION AND PRETTY MUCH
DESTROY IT IN ABOUT 24 HOURS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
REHABILITATION.
NOBODY SHOULD BE IN JAIL FOR
NONVIOLENT CRIME.
>> I'M GOING TO DO SOMETHING
UNPRECEDENTED TONIGHT.
MY CAMPAIGN WILL NOW GIVE A
FREEDOM DIVIDEND OF $1,000 A
MONTH FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR TO 10
AMERICAN FAMILIES, SOMEONE
WATCHING THIS AT HOME RIGHT NOW.
>> START FOR OUR BABIES BE I
PROVIDING UNIVERSAL CHILD CARE
FOR EVERY BABY 0 TO 5, UNIVERSAL
PRE-K FOR EVERY 3-YEAR-OLD AND
4-YEAR-OLD IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> EVERYONE UP HERE FAVORS AN
ASSAULT WEAPON BAN.
EVERYONE UP HERE FAVORS MAGAZINE
LIMITATIONS.
>> THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE BURDEN
ON MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO DID NOTHING
WRONG EXCEPT TRY TO GET THE
EDUCATION THEY NEED.
WE ARE GOING TO CANCEL ALL
STUDENT DEBT IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: KAMELA HARRIS, IT'S NOT
ABOUT COST, IT'S ABOUT
INVESTMENT.
EVERY TIME YOU HEAR THE WORD
FROM A POLITICIAN ABOUT
INVESTMENT, THAT MEANS RAISE
YOUR TAXES.
WE'RE INVESTING.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING.
ONE OF THE MORE SHOCKING
PROPOSALS FROM LAST NIGHT'S
DEBATE CAME FROM BAY TOE BOZO
ROBERT FRANCIS OROURKE WHO MADE
IT CLEAR, HE'S COMING FOR YOUR
GUNS.
GET READY.
>> YOU SAID, QUOTE, AMERICANS
WHO OWN AR-15s AND AK-47'S WILL
HAVE TO SELL TO THE GOVERNMENT,
ALL OF THEM.
THE CRITICS CALL THIS
CONFISCATION.
ARE YOU PROPOSING TAKING AWAY
THEIR GUNS AND HOW DOES THIS
WORK.
HELL, YES, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
YOUR AR-15 AND AK-47, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO ALLOW IT TO BE USED
AGAINST OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
ANYMORE.
>> Sean: HELL, YEAH, ONLY THE
CRIMINALS WILL HAVE THOSE.
YOU STAND BACK AND OBSERVE ALL
OF THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
RADICAL EXTREMIST PROPOSALS,
YOU'LL FIND ONE COMMON THEME,
CENTRALIZATION OF POWER AND
MONEY IN ORDER TO PROTECT
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS FROM